a report out this morning ranks the
world's top political risks and their
potential impact number five on the
Eurasia group's annual list is the u.s.
at home because of investigations in the
President Trump and the possibility of a
quote constitutional crisis number four
is European populism covering brexit
nationalism and the impact on the
European Union cyber gloves off is
number three highlighting the increasing
threat of cyberattacks
number two the eroding relationship
between the United States and China and
the number one risk is something called
bad seeds or the dangers of weakening
political institutions and global
relationships in Bremer President of the
Eurasia group is also a CBS News senior
global affairs contributor in good
morning they'll be with you boy this is
a cheery list let's start with bad seeds
explain exactly what bad seeds are think
of it as geopolitical climate change
it's pretty much everything that we
monitor geopolitically that matters in
the world is presently heading in a
negative direction it's been 21 years
since I started the firm that's never
been true before both domestically the
erosion of institutions the weakness of
leaders in the United States across
Europe in the United Kingdom and also
all the major relationships in the world
transatlantic US Russia US China as well
as within the Middle East they're all
becoming less sustainable and when we
usually have crises like after 9/11 the
u.s. came together the world came
together to support the United States
even the Russians did after the 2008
financial crisis the world came together
to dig out of a major recession if the
next crisis we have whether it's cyber
or terrorism are most likely the next
economic slowdown the world is so much
less resilient in its ability to respond
and these bad seeds are really
undermining them why is the world less
resilient it's less resilient because
you no longer have the willingness of
the countries to come together the
populism the nationalism for example
makes it so much harder you're gonna go
into blames Manship also the nature of
the relationship with in Europe
Europeans aren't coming together it's
every nation for itself
the Americans much more likely to blame
the Chinese and vice versa not say how
do we work together to resolve this kind
of issue the word risk is normally not a
good
thing but there you are number five with
the United States and in the from the
domestic point of view making the list
why it's very first time for the first
time a US domestic risk is there and
give it keep in mind the u.s. is the
most powerful country in the world so
it's not number one number two being
number five means we don't think it's
going to happen but the fact is this is
the year the investigations are coming
down against Trump against his family
and against his business and we know
what Trump does when you threaten him
and the things he really cares about he
hits back and his willingness to go
after the people that are threatening
him and his interests and use the powers
of the presidency in ways that perhaps
go beyond the guardrails of what is
considered legal and normal becoming
going to the Supreme Court become a
constitutional crisis I certainly
believe that our court system is strong
enough the bat Trump down if and when
that occurs the way it has over the last
two years but you can't guarantee it so
it has to be on the list
let's get your take on some of the big
headlines for today the president's
national security adviser talking about
no we're not going to pull troops out of
Syria until we get an agreement by the
Turks not to attack the Kurds yeah well
I mean let's keep in mind that the US
has 2,000 special forces on the ground
it's very different than what you have
in Afghanistan and over 10,000 American
listed men and women also the Russians
the Turks the Iranians they're the ones
that have determined the outcomes
politically and militarily in Syria not
the United States we will lose
intelligence gathering capabilities
understanding radicalism in Syria and in
the region Hezbollah on the rest you
take the 2,000 troops out that's why for
example the Secretary of State has
strongly opposed this withdrawal there's
also the Israel issue not in Yahoo
elections coming up he's really not
happy with the idea that his buddy Trump
is suddenly undermining him in his
backyard so I do suspect that pushback
means that the timing is going to get
muddied even more at the table because
the beginning of the year thanks